herzlich kommt zu einer neuen folge ich
fahre leute wir sind heute in der nähe
von koblenz und wir fahren heute amg 53
mio
[Musik]
und hinter der kamera heute ist niemand
anders als was geht was gibt es geht ihr
aber frech kaderleute erst das cabrio
erstes cabrio ist wir haben in diesem
format seien direkt das schönste dann
direkt das krasseste kabel was es gibt
es 65 du kannst sich verpissen jetzt de
safe so gucken wir mal hier rum was
haben wir für felgen drauf 20 2 alles
klar hinten auf 20 25 17 reifen geil und
guckt euch mal das interieur anleger das
ist designer und das ist wirklich so
crazy heart personalleiter hier wird wie
heißt dieses rot noch mal bedroht worden
roth helle sitze und dann diese
zierleiste digger bruder das ist ja
wirklich zu krank alter wir sehen hier
sitzheizung sitzbelüftung und
nackenheizung erst der gare du hast
wirklich was einfach alles er muss sein
einfach nur cabrio geholt damit du den
ratten heizung klub noch am grund sich
aber so echt übel strato sich die
nackenheizung das sowieso ein wahlschein
wenn du fährst jetzt richtig krass hier
sehen wir das ja da kommt die warme luft
raus ich hatte ja früher mal zwei 1860
als cabrio hatte eigentlich auch dass
hier das ding was ihr hochfährt und vor
windschutz und dass hier was hoch hätten
verwenden
das ist so ein paket mit dieser nacken
hat ja genau erklärt und ich hatte aber
sportsitze deswegen kann ich das ding
nicht haben leben einfach scheiße oder
ich hab selber erst seit drei wochen
zwei drei wochen hat der ist
jungfräulich auf jeden fall schon
eingefahren
ja ja das haben wir heute amg t 53 hat
aber ich glaube auch wie die unserer
auch also unsere unser e coupé auch ein
bisschen die probleme hin dass der
entwurf nur ein relativ hat einen
eigenen mitteln von ihr müsst ihr
einfach glauben heute ist aber nur ein
rohr für zwei blätter aber wenigstens
hat er noch eine ruhe die autos sie aber
gar nichts das ist einfach diesen
blenden und das auch so vorgeht nach
unten ja utiger das ist die krise beim
s7 und so es wächst von audi einfach
blende und das nichts für dich nicht
schrott wirklich schon mal hier sehen
wir es heute turbo fertigt er hat einen
turbolader dann auch soweit ich weiss
turbolader und ein elektrisches feld
und die machen zusammen kw 530 ps 25
meter körper hier dass hier das finde
ich wirklich mutig von dir helle
fußmatten es hat drei wochen du siehst
jetzt schauen wir hatten gestern richtig
sauer wirklich komplett mit dem auto
aufbereitet also der das nicht
ausgewaschen aber alles recht sauber
gemacht hotel ziehen wurden an das ist
also hände fußmatten liga da muss ja das
ist ja wirklich
ich wollte einfach mal gönnen und das
sieht so geil aus optischen das wirst du
dir niemals ohne regeln ist viply singen
dachte mir kommen probier's einfach
ausgerichtet ist egal wir sehen hier die
neueste version von der e-klasse um
diese beiden fahrerlebnisschalter hier
richtig geil welche lenkrad habe ich mag
sich in unserem auto auch heißt dass ich
fand das alte lenker ein bisschen geiler
sorgte damit noch immer nicht diesen
touch 4 hatten aber das finde ich nicht
schlimm ich finde nur dass es so richtig
dick das alte wahrheit viel dünner ja ok
hatte das ist schon okay aber eine sache
ist und zwar das habe ich auch gelesen
bei der recherche für das video dieser
schalter der ist ja eigentlich außerdem
vor dass er als modell und ich habe euch
dass man hier ein ich habe eben aufgaben
für vater her der bei uns im coupé da
sieht anders aus
diesen touch ja genau acht nur das
cabrio hat diesen alten schalter weil
das irgendwie mit dem knopf wir sind ja
erst hätte auch neulich hat die
komplette e klasse lehne er leute dann
würde ich sagen
rang 108 jetzt genau so liege die erste
frage dieses format ist natürlich immer
was bedeuten autos für dich vor schluss
wahllos autos haben eine riesen
bedeutung ich würde ja in der nähe von
nürburgring ich bin ja quasi mit autos
aufgewachsen bin halt früher mit meinem
papa da schon immer hingefahren haben
uns rennwagen angeguckt und so deswegen
so schnell das auto war schon immer mein
traum früher das fest selbst daran waren
und jetzt jungs und halben mannschaft
schlecht stolz darauf ist eine gute
sache vegas safe also ist ja schon was
ist schon ordentlich eine sache die ich
glaube für viele leute da draußen nicht
so ganz nachvollziehbar aber die sich
einstellt wenn man so auch in diesem
youtube blase so lebt ist dass man
irgendwann sich denkt ja keine ahnung so
ein auto wo alle anderen sagen würden
übels krass oder so also keine ahnung
seine e-klasse mit dem dreiliter diesel
so würden 90 prozent für deutschland
sagen hammer traumauto wenn du diese
blase müssen sie ist okay sein kumpel
hier vettel geht die 63 der fährten gt-r
blabla oder nicht irgendwann so ja was
wichtig ist man die perspektive nicht
verliert aber auf jeden fall hier muss
auch sagen leute jetzt wahrscheinlich
gerade schon mal gesehen also dieses
interieur hier ist ja sowas von
ausgeflippt weißt du wie diese ziele
leisten die heißen da kann ich gar nicht
sagen dass mit glänzend holzkeil gibt es
auch nur der kombination mit dem ganzen
weißen in rom ist das ja ein audio paket
jetzt komme ich das ist so ein design
und gesamtpaket
deswegen das ist ja echt also diese
kombination hier leute hier so burgunder
mäßig dann diese ziele leisten wurde und
dann dann dazu dieses helle leder das
schon wirklich krass oder wir fahren
jetzt mal kurz hier in der nähe von
mendig und hier ist jetzt hier bei rock
am ring würde ich glaube da sind auch
maria oder ja stimmt ich war bei rock am
ring genau das hier gewesen das war
damals der eingang hier kommt es dann
überall rein und hier links das halt
diese riesige fläche für jede aber
lustiger perfekt als rock am ring herum
war war ich auch noch hier in der schule
sind wir nachmittags hatten wir auch
schon autos konnten wir hier einfach mal
rasen ausfällt fahren wir sind darum
geheizt das war so geil hat richtig war
kann oder soll ich mal ganz kurz sport
sport plus an machen ja es hilft das
wirklich eine welt bei dem auto weil
jetzt und heute kaum was sie so macht
ok ja ok krass er glaubt so krank dass
er helfen
da ich will es ganz anders kommt aus dem
nichts so leute
ein ende von mehreren stationen
entfernungen gehabt
foto haus zu haus max-planck-straße
korrekt karriere danke für sagen alle ja
dank dir wird die west linken am
moderieren
das hat man uns vorbeigefahren ist es
umgedreht unser tipp zu geben wo man
gerade foto machen kann
du bist auch so nicht liegt auf was wir
fahren ja noch mal egal welcher ich
fange mal richtig sowie an dass mir auch
gar nicht aufgefallen und der kamera
gesehen
du kannst du richtig so ich bin ja soo
der lex koller leute e 350 4matic kawohl
auch ich liebe eigentlich cabrio susanne
ich liebe diesen scheiß so sehr es wurde
wirklich zeit ganz kurz wissen kommt
vorne
ja wir können auch in komplexen die
klappen aufmachen das habe ich beim c63
damals gern gemacht
niebels bei 4,6 sekunden leute übrigens
für alle zahlen fakten funktioniert hier
und sehr sehr geile kombination aus
sportlichkeit komfort jetzt gerade ist
das wie so ein alter amiq user so du
hast sound aber du gleitet zu klappen
auf den komfort habe ich wie gesagt sehr
gern gemacht beim 62 beste schon wieder
eine abdeckung also ich will das so wenn
andere leute so viel ich muss ehrlich
sagen ich bin ja bei der rp die klasse
auch von maxi mir gesehen leute und ganz
schlicht schwarz alles schwarz
zierleisten schwarz hier die so hoch
klasse in der sonne so kristallisierte
das hat auch wirklich was jetzt gerade
ist wirklich so ich streiche das
gaspedal des autors okay für uns man
schild der ausschuss person
und dann fahren wir dann so ein bisschen
warm kohl wir leben zumal hier zurück
ins cabrio rissen die nackenheizung
nackenheizung ja man kann schon sagst du
mann überlebt man überlebt das ist eine
alte sohn es ist eine harte zeiten aber
für draht- braucht wasser die top 40
damit die 50 50 das getriebeöl jetzt die
sollten wir auch warum fahren das war
ganz gut ich bin ab wann fahrer gibt ja
immer viele leute die gerade im
wirklichen sich denken nachkommen ist
ein kalt gegen sexuelle haben auch gar
keinen fall gleich warm fahren wenn die
leidenschaft für die autos mit
entwickelt dann spürst du irgendwann in
dein herz und das ist das richtige ist
die berge zu fahren
das ist hewitt ab deuce
das ist fast ein v8 mäßig mit einer
lobert im sport plus knallte bürger
könnten mehr raus als er gt stimme das
meinst du das meinte meinte lukas schon
auf dem weg hierher dass der gegner dort
ist ein gt 63 ist es sogar sechs
und der war leiser als der hier so viele
videos zeigen das halt so auf der
autobahn das hieß ja manchmal einfach
geradeaus durch sie ist ja manchmal so
autos leben die das fenster unterbrochen
erwarten diese kaum bescheid war
untergebene ja sofort gehört halt
es war halt wirklich also hier ist ja
klar hier wird immer zwei modulen
gearbeitet ja dass er nicht der rieder
sagt ja dass ich glaube beim gt war aber
fast alles viel außer dass man zu
blocken
auch in das fällt ja glaub ich weil es
hier für den tunnel hoppala 6 grad okay
dann muss ja nicht doof nur nichts wegen
mir fern des mofas wird schon okay
toni muss man mitnehmen will muss mit
mir einmal reinigen soll nun ein
bisschen länger wäre echt korrekten die
fälligen ganz bleiben aber dafür kann
jetzt endlich nicht garantieren aber ich
habe auch schon drin
merkwürdig ist richtig ganz ganz krasse
kombination heute das lenkrad ist so
breit und ist so shafiq dieses auto aber
der ist so hart am gas in sport plus
also sofort wenn ich einen kleinen
gasbefehl gebe jetzt geholfen das sieht
auch so garstig doppelte land heiter
eine fürs auto eine für die landschaft
hat kann so langsam ein bisschen kann
ihnen absolut kicker oder war so ja
[Musik]
nach oben hin immer stärker wird ich
würde also aber die die die mutter in
dem golf 5 hinter uns oder was ist die
mod veröffentlicht oder wegen sich merkt
also erfahren hier nicht ganz genau
tempolimit muss ich gestehen und dieses
hinten dran das hat bei uns die gegend
hier fährt jeder hier ist einfach fakt
hier gibt's nur verkehrs empfehlung also
hier alle real talk die sich hier der
juni caroline die fed sich auch im 200
hier fahren alle wie bescheuert ich
verstehe das nicht jetzt haben wir ein
7er golf gtd hinter uns der verbissen
schneller als gleich wieder raus kann es
theoretisch auf 100 mal kicken ja kicken
wir einmal auf 100 leute
und jetzt
[Musik]
jawohl über den kumpel hier wohl jetzt
erst mal sacken ausgerenkt
ja da kommt vieles ist nicht wissen auf
was aber keine kurven kann auch schön
ins schwitzen immer ich versuche es
ja und danach darum am meisten hasst
dann geht er damit nicht runter
ja ja freundeskreis heute hat er mal
drauf und das blog aber die klinge auch
immer recht ähnlich
also diese auch schon wahrscheinlich
sehr herzlich fraktion die die 43 53
modelle alle gleich also wirklich alle
ähnlich nicht genau gleich aber sehr
ähnlich
das ist sehr schön körperlich stelle
jetzt einfach mal nach gehört ist die
straße konzentrieren oder jung nach
gehör schalten ja genau
war diese schaltvorgänge sind wirklich
schon sehr schön gemacht habe ich sagen
das hat wohl auch beim chef der platz
hinten raus weil es so ja das finde ich
auch so sexy an euro das ist schon sehr
sehr schön muss nicht sagen dass wir
dich also muss ich sagen
man merkt schon dass das alles auch
schon programmiert ist so ich das merkt
man auf jeden fall das rund das runter
den gasen geboren und die schaltvorgänge
aber es wird trotzdem kann ich mich auch
wieder auf der bremse gelandet doch wie
sie ja ja weil als plötzlich mit absicht
dafür brauchen wir das so ja passieren
wollen diese mich auch nicht nach hinten
[Gelächter]
aber da kannst du nicht weil direkt das
polizei ich weiß nicht naja also die
haben da ihre station zu station zum was
trotzdem wurde kann ja eigentlich
manuellen modus absaufen
also wenn der sony toren kommen das ist
der der seitlich abreise wenn wir zum
zweiten bist und du lässt die drehzeit
zu weit runter fallen dann schaltet er
dann irgendwann aber nach oben lässt er
sich an den begrenzer reihe neuer das
was ich eben die hätte ich auch gern
dass bei solchen nach es macht natürlich
keinen sinn es wird mir zu bauen aber
dass der begrenzer so klingt wie bei
japanischen krass getunten autos oder
motorrädern
das finde ich auch sagen dies sogar aber
hier ist es ja
leute denn jetzt einmal autobahn und
lala ja wohl jetzt komplett
ja der schub ist ganz souverän wirklich
und die schaltvorgänge und das ist jetzt
180 in dem cabrio cabrio und es ist so
ruhig und bevor es zurück würden die
sowie die leute kommen wir besser mal zu
bewerten die fängt wie immer mit dem
aussehen anlaufender skala von eins bis
zehn wie immer gibt es hier eigentlich
acht punkte aber ich ziehe einen punkt
ab ein paar details an dem auto nicht
gefallen einerseits die farbkombination
ist für mich persönlich dann doch ein
bisschen zu funky andererseits die
felgen die finde ich auch irgendwie hab
ich mir nicht so gefallen so breite
elemente da am rand über nicht so ganz
mein geschmack muss ich ehrlich sagen
sieben von zehn die beschleunigung ist
stabil 4,6 sekunden von null auf hundert
das gibt den abstimmung mit allen
bisherigen bewertungen eine ganz klare
sieben von zehn ebenfalls weil der
coolness kann der wagen natürlich
punkten ich finde caro einfach fresh
leute das ist einfach geil das dach
runter machen kann offen herum fahren
kann
das auto sieht wirklich auch sehr
wuchtig aus wenn das dach ab bis 8 von
10 punkten und nicht nur cool ist es
sondern auch relativ praktisch zumindest
für ein cabrio man kann da wirklich mit
vier leuten gut drin sitzen man merkt
eben es basiert auf der e klasse die ein
ganz gutes platzangebot habe
beziehungsweise basiert sich auf der e
klasse es ist ja noch vollwertige e
klasse im vergleich zum coupé dass
sieben von zehn wir der praktikabilität
bekommen hat muss ich aber hier einen
punkt dafür abziehen das einfach das
verdeck im kofferraum doch platzt
abnimmt und dadurch der kofferraum schon
eine ganze ganze ecke kleiner wird immer
ein bisschen mehr hacker hat sechs von
zehn dann kommen wir zu wieder mal sehr
schwierigen kategorie preis leistung ich
habe ja gesagt das auto ist irgendwo so
eine eierlegende wollmilchsau man kann
mit vier leuten fahren
man hat sound man hat komfort man kann
cruisen man kann locker easy langstrecke
fahren und das ist nicht zu laut aber
das kostet seinen preis 124.000 euro
meinte lukas kostet das auto der version
die wir hier haben und das ist einfach
schon richtig harter brocken da kann ich
eigentlich nicht mehr als 5 von 10
punkten geben schlussendlich der komfort
ist wie ich bereits angedeutet habe
einfach stark dieses auto ist wirklich
eins mit dem ich sehr gerne lange
strecken fahren würde ich habe da
überhaupt keine bedenken dass mir die
wirbelsäule durchschüttelt oder das mit
roten ohren dann komme weil das auto zu
laut dass man sich leise haben kann aber
logischerweise muss es hier auch
gegenüber dem coupé einen punkt
abzugeben weil es eben einfach
bauartbedingt dadurch das ist ein cabrio
ist ein ticken lauter ist beim fahren
aber alles in allem ein ganz ganz
frisches auto das wirklich sehr sehr
viele tunnel in sich vereint und auf 41
von 60 punkte
in der gesamtwertung kommt starker wert
so schneidet das auto gegen alle anderen
bisher getesteten autos ab das war so
weit von mir heute ich freue mich auf
den nächsten sonntag bis dahin macht's
gut